khan is gonna stick to the marduk we
have the random stage picked as arctic
snowfall to start it out from the outset
and uh i feel like that could help and
it could also hurt mark is so dangerous
by the wall as is brian but we're gonna
go right into the matchup
these guys are ready to go
let's see how it plays out
good block
man that punish is so so good
oh my god dude
sometimes you gotta let no you're not
afraid
three three two
that's my area code let's go oh my
goodness
gotta be very weary and look at that
first round of beloved that's already
way better than he did that first set
they played fight
absolutely yeah he's got the first round
nice good block
interesting both
positions and look at that great punish
there from khan khan is locked and
loaded ready to go that addition that
martic has that extra move really helps
out uh against a lot of punishes that he
has available again not just from the
highs the maze or the whip punishes but
also from certain low moves
yeah absolutely rage available now but
he goes for that big call out and it's
not going to work out khan staying very
composed finishes it with a down threat
nice powerful sidestep
yeah threading the needle here let's see
what he does with it misses the back
three
oh this is unfortunate this is gonna
hurt it's gonna add up it's not gonna do
as much damage as we normally would
expect by the wall
yeah well that's big though right he he
let khan get back in and launch him when
it should have been his launch it looks
like just chipping away at him
yo big count before three
gets the full charge come on dude
what's
[Music]
oh is he dead he he was in the air oh my
god no
he was
he was in the air he was in the running
slash
oh my god that wasn't enough
i thought that was going to kill i
thought that ray jar was killed that was
crazy
playing big time
oh
yo below taking it back
taking it back oh
was that necessary overkill the rage art
the exclamation point here in this first
match
fake khan of 1-0
yep
what's a call out there from khan on the
timing just down forward one catches
below running in trying to end that
round and again mark i feel like bella
is a little bit flustered at the moment
because he's dropping combos he dropped
multiple combos in that match he also uh
is getting too antsy you know he's
running in he's being bit careless he's
whipping a lot as well this is not the
bullet that we're used to seeing but
yeah i mean khan is composed as ever and
he's just kind of in the driver's seat
man he's just looking comfortable
he's uh busting out the you know the
famous smarter catchphrase hope your
camera's ready for this ain't gonna last
long he's letting people know like he he
wants to do it in one set
but that was good stuff in the open
round you know below came out had some
fire in him but you know the the the
resolve here from fake khan he was able
to kind of harness the energy still that
he kind of continued from that first set
that they played and really come out on
top man that down forward one at the
very end
so good at at the call out there that
was that was great stuff
yeah yeah he just knew the timing he
knew that bill i wanted to come in and
you know the thing is when you're in the
winner's side of the grand finals you
have that cushion you have those three
matches that you can you can afford to
throw away right so you know he can
afford to play a little bit more risky
and that's what we're seeing here from
khan he's playing a little bit more
risky a little bit more like he doesn't
give a damn because it's gonna put below
off but also he can afford to take those
risks whereas bella can't belong is in
the loser's side if he loses one first
to three it is over and he is one nil
down now but you've gotta finish your
plate you gotta finish your food when
you get a combo make sure that you
maximize on the opportunity anyway here
we go walls are back in play
nice they traded blows there
good
oh my gosh he is locked and loaded ready
to go even has the right and proper
punish there
here we go oh my goodness
maybe not and it's crazy because you
know he's usually the bigger character
right
yeah oh my god he's dead
out of the mist
oh my gosh i don't know what just
happened too but do it again fight
you see belong actually let go of his of
his uh artistic he said he thought it
was over
yeah what are you standing up for
oh yeah here we go
yo he's on he's on some stuff right now
nice python hey what are you doing
that [ __ ] out here nice
he might be able to tie it up
stay composed
this is angry below right now angry
below for the magic four here we go
taking it to the wall
hey
oh he's trying to catch him again
nice duck
nice
yeah great transition of the bts cancel
follow up here let's see what he does
doubtforward one again star of the show
nice
jesus
you have to get this match on the board
no break on the oneplus 2
nice step sideways again what's the
situation
down two no
let's go
oh oh oh oh oh
punish
oh um this match is crazy you know i um
yeah i don't know how to explain it i
mean the momentum shift
brian coming back
really putting
a different perspective into how they've
been playing so far because you know i
feel like
khan tried to play a little bit more
defensively he tried not to interrupt as
much as he used to and that kind of
led him to where bella took over
momentum-wise not only momentum wise but
the pacing really fell into what he's
more comfortable with
and khan can't do that khan cannot let
his opponent take over because once he
does below he's happy to take lead and
he definitely did
yeah and you can see this is a very
emotionally charged first of three set
here mark in this grand finals you know
both guys are swinging they there's the
plane started the throw breaks are still
there the punishment is still there the
combo everything is still there but you
can tell that the decisions these guys
are making they want to hurt each other
right this is uh both guys want to run
really really badly because i have a lot
to prove mark both guys have a lot to
prove here by winning here today on you
know in an official uh tournament on the
second channel you know there's so much
to play for for these guys and we're
going straight back in no dilly dallian
you can tell it's serious because we
have less than a minute between matches
that's how you know it's real anyways
going into this brimstone and fire tied
up one apiece
i can't wait to see it here we go
it's all gonna come down to the mind
game at the end here we go one much
apiece
more powerful game nice punish again
that hatching punished
marduk is able to really kind of put the
hurt and still keep the pressure on
oh nice back dash he's kind of changing
it up again
yeah it's almost like almost like a
completely different person
wow the sidestep
bella is sticking to him like glue he
just wants to apply the pressure
nice orbital i love it no
oh my gosh oh
he doesn't even do that kick normally
that's crazy all right
i think he charges while he's feeling
himself the last time he did that he
lost nine rounds straight be careful
trying to catch him good move
see what he does
oh man
khan not letting him get those free hits
on his legs
no break oh it's adding up
goes for the ball up here let's see what
he does
oh i thought he was going to let it rip
doesn't matter
taking that round tied up on rounds here
fight tied up on games and rounds
yeah and you see how he goes for those
down threes but he changes up the timing
each time
so that it's harder for blood to low
power even if he's looking for it but a
big back slap backhand they're taking
time to the wall oh my god
he's gonna keep him there let's see what
he does
oh how did that hit oh my god how did it
hit like that
oh
chunks of damage
he punishes the downford one trying to
catch him stepping down forward one good
punishment
the jab the jab rush the mix-up here
let's see what he does orbit towel where
are you going with that
the combo instant watching 1734
put the brakes on big counter hit this
is gonna hurt into the throw no tries to
go for carry
rage
oh my goodness how is he going to keep
the oh with the
the reigns
wow
the law interruption with ocon when he
was on minus the disrespect into the
three plus four mark we're one much away
from her reset
hey man if you're gonna do the reset
make it happen i wanna see blood on the
dance floor let's make it happen
balal is uh
he's powering up before our eyes
this
playing with a little bit more
confidence than what we saw in that
first set a little bit more
it's working and
a little bit more emotion that's what
i'm telling you like sometimes you can
read um a player on on how they're
feeling when they're playing a match you
could tell that bilal is not happy with
the way that he lost in that green that
winners finals and he is uh back with a
vengeance he is playing um he's
interrupting a lot more he's he's
committing a lot more to certain things
which he wasn't committing before before
in winter's finals he was just uh
coasting along you know he wasn't he was
scared to pull the trigger now he's here
grand finals one match away from
resetting the bracket and he's playing
very um
confidently and emotionally he's really
good at pressing um
four buttons together at the end of
rounds too he's really good at that
very accurately he's just testing his
buttons like i'm sure that's what is
that's the only thing right just you
know testifying
i like that they're doing button checks
between rounds now that that works for
me
arctic snowfall this is interesting
because
this is interesting because like mark's
so good with walls right martic is
amazing with walls
but he opted to go for the open stage
well one more much needed for below
and you know if you can ask me my honest
honest opinion here below right now is
untouchable
is untouchable look at the way he's
moving look at the way he's engaging the
match
yeah
you know he may be down on life but look
at the way he's moving says the
different story
for sure
now khan his one match in this uh grand
finals was on the infinite stage right
so he's just going back to what worked
big damage
very confident round there just poking
away nothing too silly no launches just
pure
poking
and that's what could mess things up
like you know you're moving you're
feeling a certain way but khan just
slowly slowly now look at this switching
defensively
see what happens oh my gosh
nice wow
still able to land the hit here let's
see what he does
nice punishment good job good punishment
oh my god
sidestep downward speed able to close it
out there we go
the big switch
turned all the way around instant down
forward one at the start of the round
gets the trade
in his favor
okay
doesn't get the punish doesn't matter
let's see what he does
knocking his prey chains of misery
two rounds away but this tackle's gonna
hurt if you're gonna break it
is so good at knowing when that low is
going to come out
miss time to okie though
down three the pope's from marduk gets
the life lead back here come on big with
no punishment below
oh
nice spear tackle the follow up here
oh he delayed he hesitated
yeah
is it gonna be a tournament win for khan
or will bella reset the brackets
very very important match coming up so
we're down to our final match here in
our first set of grand finals it could
go either way you know below if he's
able to win he's going to push it to
another set but khan with that momentum
especially towards the end there
looking really really really strong
um i don't know what's going on man it's
like the way that that uh khan is
playing
sometimes his movement will look super
super crisp and he'll just be chilling
right then out of nowhere the jabs are
coming out this the the compact pressure
it's it's it's interesting he's like
able to change
his uh
his engine type like on the fly it's
it's nuts yeah that's the thing about
the thing about mark is that he's got a
very good back that she's always has you
know even tech attack two and before his
his his back dash has always been super
super good right in that in that final
round you know he saw a slight little
back dash uh forced the whiff down
forward one and the entire time you know
he's realized that blah wants to stick
to him and pressure him so much that he
can't do anything about it um there's no
hop kick to worry about nothing like
that so
you know bella is gonna probably go back
to the wall stage and just try to stick
to him as close as possible not give him
the space to move around and poke him
with the jabs and down threes because
that's what's been adding up here bilal
he is one match away still
to get this reset but khan
himself one match away from winning this
entire tournament what is it going to be
it all comes down to this have you got
lazy lads
well it could be the last match of the
tournament
oh look at the moves are coming out good
punisher
let's see how he approaches goes through
that huge punish there
hey
look like a float did you get the wall
oh
nice stuff oh my goodness
nice
trying to go for the orbitals defeat the
low and khan on the board here
and reads against khan has a good lead
right now
nice
oh you know
the way he used that python explosion
too was so hard to see incoming but the
law just kind of knowing from the
match-up experience when to do it oh my
gosh that downforward one though
he's looking to run away with it but the
orbital
yep
oh my god a hit
out of range
punish
and the low ladies and lads con
fates
pushing towards the wall what's he gonna
do
don't tell me you're gonna find a final
round don't tell me orbital gets blocked
khan's still fighting back down forward
one gets confirmed
oh my gosh this could be the start of
something nasty
oh lady
final final round here in the grand
finals what is it gonna be a reset or a
tournament win for khan
it all comes down to this round
nice block
it's back this is crazy seeing both of
these players pushing each other to
their limits orbital heavy got bizarre
should be taking it to the wall here
this is a massive opportunity but he
drops the combo
you have to be careful oh my gosh this
could do it
it's going to be an interesting setup
ready to bail the ball black one ladies
and gents we have a reset here with a
master event for south asia toc
it all comes down to this final first
two three
oh my gosh
great stuff
and again we gotta remember we talk
about the winners final set was so
dominant between both of these players
it was what nine rounds to one but this
time getting pushed to the very edge oh
my god the situation and how we got
there the law making that comeback he's
slowly adjusting and he's working out
he's slowly adjusting similar to what we
saw at the lcq at twt 2019 finals
oh man on the verge of defeat too on the
verge
yeah man he was on the verge of the feed
but he clawed it back and those call
outs were the orbital that is definitely
some good at a second guys yeah um look
the orbitals mark the orbitals man it
really made the big difference because
you try to go for the lows and instead
of blocking them he's like you know what
i'm just gonna crush them
instead of blocking or low parry them he
knew like when the down three would come
out when the low jab or when the down
four would come out he was already in
the air
in orbit so to speak ready to knock him
down and he definitely did that and
capitalized on so many situations not
just that he blocked the downfall when
he needed he did the wall sending one
pushed him to the wall got the combo got
the advantage
but man
it was too tough to call it could have
gone either way the momentum shift
between both of those players but you
know slowly and surely
edging them out
towards the end it's all about clutch
you know when two very skilled players
are going at it it matters what happens
at the very end of these rounds and the
decision making
is gonna wear on you over time you know
going to this final set i wouldn't be
surprised you know even though all of
our matches up to this point in this
grand finals have been closed i wouldn't
be surprised if we saw a blowout
sometimes those decisions will wear on
you
and
have effects on you
like there's no way he's going to
orbital again there's no way he's gonna
do this down back to counter it again
i don't know and and i hate to say you
know looking at brian fury
he's kind of limited on how he can break
down an opponent what happens if
khan just stands there yeah what's gonna
happen sure
i don't know man
this is gonna be exciting so i'm just
thinking of the situation oh guess who
comes out guess what yeah
that's not martial main character
that's not dude this is a different kind
of bird
let me tell you that this is a different
kind of bird
yeah 100 man here we go khan going with
his main character here we go the geese
is out the goose is loose here we go
reset grand finals first of three
oh what's that
i'm gonna
no
not like this
[Music]
perfect
okay well i guess we'll get back into
that one again uh i'm not sure what
happened there uh maybe he did he pick a
stage
i don't think so i don't know anyway um
if that's anything to go by mark we
could talk about that one then we have
we've he's gone to the um to the geese
do you agree with that
are you that's his main character yes of
course i agree with it
i feel like
sure he tried with marta he had some
success with marduk but you're always
gonna be able to play
a million times better when you can use
a character that you don't even have to
think about using instinctively
things start to kick in certain punishes
certain special special things
specialist things that come out in the
matchup and you know you got to give it
up for both these players i'm sure they
know some very very intricate details
about not only the player matchup but
also the character matchup and that's
the kind of stuff i want to see i want
to see
stuff like oh man that works you could
do that in that situation situations
where you think like oh brian has an
advantage here
but i don't know this is what i like to
see is when all the crazy things happen
that these guys have blabbed out and
practiced and prepped for
i think that'll happen yeah but um it's
not going to happen if we have a button
check i'll tell you that
i'm sorry i'm yeah
me too i'm just trying to hide it man
look good thing we have our sunglasses
that i can't see how angry you are but
yeah like uh we'll be getting back into
that one very shortly i'm sure because
both these guys want to play each other
asap um but yeah the geese is gonna be a
complete it's gonna be a different uh
dynamic for sure such a different
character to to um to marduk so bella is
gonna have to be ready here but on the
other hand it's like uh modok was a
character that he used in the winner's
side and now for the first set of the
grand finals so khan hasn't played his
geese versus velaz bryan uh before so
there's there's new there's like a fresh
new set it all comes down to this first
whoever wins this is gonna be the
champion
yeah and i don't know it's a tough call
because it's a completely different
match that we've been discussing and
watching um leading up to this i i'd
like to say if it was martic again it
could i could have maybe had a better
prediction but because it's geese
man the thing is you have to be
confident to pick
whatever character you're going into
grand finals right you have the
opportunity to change say you lose that
opening match you can always change
but that's a statement in itself like
you know what it's time to bring out my
my my big guns right
you know bilal has been using brian the
entire way yeah i don't think he's gonna
switch
yeah and he's warm right he's warm with
that character he's hot
he's on fire yeah
absolutely yeah so uh and that and that
means a lot as well and below has the
confidence you know he lost very
convincingly guys if you missed it it
was nine rounds to one
to uh uh to khan against bellar with the
marduk and to be able to make that come
back in the final final round the
momentum you're going to get is pretty
damn crazy so far he's concentrating
hard um and again this is what he wanted
to do he wanted to prove to his sponsor
he wanted to prove to his fans he wanted
to prove to himself that he is a
tournament champion here
and that he still has what it takes even
though he didn't have the best
tournament performance when he most
wanted it you know he's here now on the
tekken online challenge master event for
south asia he is one set away from
taking this uh taking this entire
tournament it's all to play for mark
mander it's it's very emotionally
charged you see the way these guys are
playing i've watched a lot of play i've
played beloved offline and online and
i'm telling you this is not how he
usually plays he's playing very much by
his feel he's playing with emotion he
wants this badly man
yeah i mean if you're not playing with
the emotion i mean
i mean i guess you not all of us can be
robots and and robotic on how we do this
but
i've seen him too like you know in
different tournaments you know i haven't
seen him in an offline setting too much
but i could tell and you know there was
that event that we went to in the
ukraine the way he played and though
after he lost that set like for example
versus jdcr he was torn he was talking
he was thinking about his
the way he reacted
he he was more focused on the game than
realizing he has to get get out of the
seat so someone else can play it
it takes a toll on you and you know i
can only imagine what's going on in
these players heads is they go in
between matches and they make these
decisions on not only what stage bit
what what to do in-between rounds how to
change the pacing anyways we're here
this is the grand finals yes and if it's
another button check i'm gonna eat my
headset
it's an asteroid it'll probably taste
good just just so you guys know it
probably tastes good
but man i'm i'm i'm ready for this this
is what i've been waiting for
i think everyone is man i think everyone
wants to see some good ass tech in here
man i think everyone wants to see this
and see what the conclusion is going to
be all comes down to this later that's
here we go grand finals
and it's going to be brian versus geese
and this is a stage which can work
pretty well for brian you see most brown
players often go to the stage because of
the big damage potential
hey here we go let's see what he does
goes for the throw
i see i see i like it creating space
opportunities for himself whoa he wasn't
ready
stand up
oh my god
there's not long left though not long
left hello hello
oh nice
that's the thing too is like when you're
standing there what is bragging to do
and it's already been proven that khan
is really good at sniffing out that that
oh yes it's gonna hurt
again he means business
um
how is he going to deal with it what's
going to happen
oh big with massive massive commitment
there and khan is going to cash in with
that standing
too what he does the law
only only a little bit of life left oh
my gosh he keeps him there
oh he misses it that could have been it
range available
nice keep out
round
from there wow
here we go
pushing towards it
oh my gosh
the defense from below but it can't hold
up all the time he has rage available
this could be huge damage
oh my geez
it doesn't
oh my god oh yeah
[Music]
nice final round
i had three heart attacks and i felt my
dinner from last night oh my gosh
here we go
final round here match number one grand
final reset
who's gonna get off to the winning start
so important pressure from khan now
oh no
[Music]
wow what a measurement
i love it i love it yeah
and khan draws first blood here in the
grand finals reset
he played very very clean you know again
going down towards the last round could
have gone either way but man
i can't help but think you know like
looking at the matchup and how it's kind
of playing out there are certain things
that we've seen
um
adjustment wise from below you know
maybe he hasn't adjusted maybe he's
still thinking mentally that he's in the
marduk matchup right
but his offense is not
elevating to the same level that i think
that khans is right now because khan
he's landing all the big stuff he's
setting him up trying to bait him out
for certain things and he's kind of
waiting for the reaction i don't know
man it's it's looking tough for bella
but again one of the things that we've
seen from bill all over time is he does
make adjustments but when is that going
to kick in you do not want to get in the
hole way too far
yeah yeah i mean uh you know with the
geese it's a different dynamic it's
almost like
you know
khan's a different player now you know
uh it's crazy with uh let's see how lol
can can can answer back the adaptation
has to be made again you know he's been
playing against the mark for such a long
time uh for two sets of first three he
played against the mark and now he's
playing versus the geese he's gonna keep
the walls in play we're going to the
mission with dojo here we go the choice
of stage four below each time that he
takes a loss but you don't want to lose
this match you lose this match you're
down 2-0 it does not look good for you
here we go round one yeah but i'm
getting a lot how do you bring it back
under pressure he's pretty damn good
let's see what he does here you know
we've seen him come back from the
loser's side before
oh he had opportunity to get those flat
but
not able to pull the trigger
side step three
you need to see the confidence that we
saw him play in that last set
do not be afraid
nice good punish there gets the jab kick
to the law taking that first round here
he desperately needs to get on the
scoreboard
oh
nice kind of threading it in here look
at the pressure here come on now making
the push here but a big mocking counter
here
oh my god again
it doesn't matter doesn't matter he
still
cleaned it up
focused no key charge this time he ain't
testing his buttons anymore one bar
meter for con to work with one standing
two could be curtains
and that's what he has to watch out for
that meter that wall is gonna hurt
oh
again that should be dead no what
happened
round four
all right almost got under the bar
immediate to work with now it's so back
and forth here mark but can could not
finish it he needs to close it out
good break
went straight for the change once again
i feel like he was waiting for that
opportunity trying to see what his
opponent was going to do on wake up
oh
and what a way to scout it out bottom of
the booming in
[Music]
down four no counter ahead down one down
four this time
decent damage here at the wall
has to be careful oh sidestep attack oh
my goodness
oh no we're punished
plus frames good break
oh
oh the countdown
oh my gosh all right
it's been a long day it's been a fun day
it's been a day of
competition i'll tell you that we are
now tied up here in our grand finals
reset
fate khan has one match but
this year the law has one match as well
now only two more matches separate them
from the championship
i'm i'm loving the defense from from
villa you know he's trying to mitigate
the the big damage that geese could
potentially get in in these panic
situations where where bilal has the
plus frames he's dashing up waiting for
an opportunity he's not overextending
he's trying not to overextend right and
this is what's happened sometimes when
you play when when khan plays you know
he get he gets put on the back foot and
he starts to lose confidence can bella
do that to khan can he can he suck the
confidence out of him and run away with
his momentum mark i ask you now khan has
lost with the geese what does he do what
did he do now i think he's sticking with
the geese but what stage is he gonna go
to is he gonna go to the howard estate i
i just don't know we haven't been here
before
well i don't know it's tough because
we've seen in the matchup previously
when he was using martic he went he
wasn't afraid to go to openstage right
was not afraid to go to open stage but i
feel like
okay we're in violet systems we are in
violence he partic he picked this one in
particular
for what reason maybe i don't know but
maybe it's just something that he's
comfortable in either way this is gonna
be a decisive match because we are gonna
have a lead change no matter what
nice job series here
[Music]
whoa the delay second hit
soccer kick follow-up here goes for the
big swipe unable to get anything out of
it but about even on life either way
both of these players have to bring to
the table
why oh yeah
a close first round here
put the brakes on it i like it
can you continue this momentum right now
looking really really good
the way he's been kind of controlling
and
limiting what what khan can do as far as
you know approaching him
but all that changes once he has meters
though you gotta remember that all that
changes one meter when the meter is in
play
is in the zone right now but you can see
it in his movement his watch waiting for
any opportunity he can't on the back
foot back three two to release the
pressure we're going to the wall who
finds his opening
all right he has him here let's see what
he does he does have the life lead
god with the pressure here at the wall
you gotta watch out for those down
forward twos as well
yep
is he gonna take this lead
he gets his wife he gets the wall
what's the adjustment here
these guys are going nuts
trying to throw him hey great
understanding too nice punish definitely
with the jabs three plus fours keep out
stay away from me one bar meter four
pound to work with
oh he didn't get it dash in
just outside of rages walk it off
this is how it's smart okay oh nice
interrupt
all right counter knife attack
with that one two was crucial
two balls of me i have for connie oh
punish he's testing him
i like it the law he's gonna get the
ball
no very closely just shy
nice
interrupt that back three two
oh he missed the dashboard trying to get
the one two series
not able to do it but khan doesn't have
a slight lead here in the round
on the reverse sweep three rounds
straight can he do it jab back three
good punish
oh man this is such an important round
here too
nice gets the knock down
yeah
it's gonna be a hard comeback
and the fireball on
you
yeah
man this is okay this is too close of a
set this is way too close but now let's
talk about the situation khan is up two
to one here in this grand finals reset
he only needs one more game to win the
entire tournament
one more game here the law has to come
back here he needs to tie it up if he's
not able to tie it up it's gonna be all
over he's gonna get second place he's
been in situations like these before his
clutch
has been legendary in certain situations
what does he need to do what do you
think he needs to do to come back with
brian here
yeah i mean the thing is that in those
first two rounds of the last match you
know he put the pressure on you know he
did played very defensively in that
close range he made sure not to
overextend and fall for things like the
parry and and any panic moves that he
might have thrown out but he was in his
face and he was applying pressure to
khan and that's where he was not
comfortable right after winning those
first two rounds he started to back off
a little bit he started to release the
pressure and allowed khan to get back in
and apply his his game plan right three
rounds straight he was able to get
that's uh that's the problem that below
you know he got too comfortable with the
with the round lead right let khan back
in he needs to go back to the mishima
dojo apply the pressure do not let do
not let the situation get to you
try to take it to a final match if
possible
here we go back to the machine i mean
this is his this is his favorite right
this is the one that he likes
yes this is what he likes but he needs
to have the right approach here he can't
be too scared he can't be too uh passive
in this situation can belong take it to
a final match or it's kind of in the
tournament here we go
tries to keep him there let's see what
he does
oh
caught him convergent side wall
oh that sucks
kicked in the face
i'm looking to close it out let's see
what he does how is he going to handle
this
doesn't cause downfall caliber
what a brilliant counter it's serious
no rage football
no break either
oh my goodness
this is not looking good it's below
giving it up
is this khan's tournament to win what's
gonna happen here
hey that's one way to start it
yep
hey
again good parry release the pressure
get out that corner
this is all below right now
okay nice
good spacing good spacing
and again look at this the timing the
spacing the rhythm that these players
are playing at oh he tried to get the
while 71 launch not able to get it
think about the position
see what he does
sidestep attack
gets rid of the fireball
thanks good job
so close so tense right now one bar
meter to work with khan trying to find
his opening catches him with the second
hit of that string
rage available
oh great block punishment
right there oh my gosh
and the last fake con is on tournament
point now milan on the back foot and
khan has muted to work with as well if
you want to close it out
oh he's just watch how that jab punish
gets the knock down
and he has meters he has to be very very
careful
punish
oh man those knees are working he's
gonna have to be careful
you got him in he's got him in the
corner no break on the throw
oh no
second throw
what's gonna happen
open up open up scoop them up that would
have been crazy
meter and rage available below he's
playing very passive now he doesn't want
to take any massive risk down forward
one ladies and gentlemen
it's below i'm gonna take it to a final
match or card with the entire tournament
it comes down to this
here we go
good start hypercard
oh my gosh he's pushing he's pushing
him
this
no no rage available can you make a
comeback kind of a small life lead raise
your eyes bent
back one
[Music]
time
can you finish it
is the last we're getting a final final
match
oh my god
oh my gosh it's come down to this guys
everybody that's watching
we have one more match to go the final
match of the tournament
khan and bilal
going at it back and forth it's brought
us here
in i mean
how else would we have it spag we're
going to the final match
we might as well go to the final round
it couldn't finish any other way ladies
and gents south asia thank you so much
for tuning in
you guys
have been part of history here
the first south asia tech and online
master event mark it is final match
who's gonna take it who is going to take
it i don't know what's going on
it's hard to say the momentum the
weights shifting going back and forth
both of these players deserve to win but
hey only one of them is going to be able
to someone's going to be salty
and i'm here for it i'm here for it i
can't wait
oh okay so
um
like what what is khan gonna do now i
mean we're going to the final final
match man it all comes down to this it
is
the first to one essentially for who's
gonna take this tekken online challenge
master event 300 points on the line the
winner of this will be number one on the
leaderboard here for the south asia tech
online challenge leaderboard it's all to
play for man it's you know khan as well
someone who hasn't been able to get that
big tournament win for an official
tournament uh traveling around with his
friends and seeing all of his friends
prosper and and nasra bella picked up by
nasa esports one of the biggest esports
uh teams in the middle east and you know
wanted to prove to his sponsor to
himself and to his fans that he can win
these big tournaments that the lcq was
not a one-off it was not a fluke
it all comes down to this one match mark
man and who has the composure and the
tenacity and the will and the desire to
win
yeah and and looking at the entire
tournament you know
a lot of people expect a wise honey a
lot of people expected arsene ash to do
well and win this tournament but you're
looking at the two players here that
maybe a lot of people didn't expect to
get this far or even win the tournament
but it's gonna be one of these two a
legendary
moment is about to befall us
and again only one of these players is
gonna be able to take the glory i i
can't even call it it's it's it's
something that i'm excited to see and i
can't wait to see the salt online
afterwards
i'm sorry i'm evil yeah
it's such a lie such a massive life
deficit bella had in that final round it
was the light at the end of the tunnel
was there
khan could see it but he let it blind
him he looked right into that light and
he couldn't see the end and below took
it from him now he has
that last sequence that we saw you know
ending it up he went for a punish right
but it didn't hit and the law was locked
and loaded ready knew that the second
hit was high hit him with that wall
standing attack and it was all over that
was all she wrote
but man
you got to think about it you got to be
on point this is the final match
only three rounds
separate you between the tournament
victory and uh second place man it's
gonna be a lonely second place too oh
boy
oh yeah a hundred percent i mean
for khan you know he he got there into
the winner's side if he loses here now
from the final uh you know in the final
match after being in the winner's side
it's going to hurt him but for bilal the
journey to get that run back against the
monarch and then you know build his way
up make these amazing comebacks time and
time and time again
and then you know if he's ever if he
actually loses it now i know he's going
to be heartbroken but i wonder who you
guys at home look who you guys think is
going to win who do you guys want to win
i don't care who you guys think is going
to win because i don't know when i just
want to hear who you guys want to win
this baby
in the chat let us know violet system
this is where it's all coming down
yes
oh boy
this is insane stuff man i'm very glad i
got to commentate this especially with
you mark it's been good man it's been
fun but it all comes down to this let's
go
oh yeah my brother happy to be here with
you grand finals reset final match of
the tournament below and khan going at
it only one of these players will be our
champion
look at this the way they're starting it
off right now
the way they're picking the shots
the rhythm the way they're playing
yeah
with the slight likely let's see what he
does how is he gonna handle it again
early on you want to be able to get that
lead you do not want to have to deal
with geese once he has meter especially
if he has two bars a meter oh my
goodness
absolutely good pressure here from both
guys don't can't have a small life here
jab pressure no brake again rage
available yo he's oh he's been dropping
those throw breaks
and khan is taking notice oh my goodness
you're gonna try to let me let me toss
your car into the air it's not good
enough
oh down four counter hit here we go khan
strikes first blood
oh no you're punished
unfortunately
got away without one con
this high temp situation right now
oh yeah
he threw him right through the board one
what is he doing trying to bait out
something
he's playing so tight compared to how we
saw him playing earlier just so one
match ago
nice back one two the follow-up here
oh my gosh
yo khan is trying to run away with it he
is trying to take this tournament right
now
nice
point
below
he's on the back foot now can't see the
light the end of the tunnel once again
can belong make a reverse sweep he's
playing so passive compared to how he
was playing last match
looking for that opening let's see how
he does it look at this compact play
from khan keeping the pressure
especially by the wall
it'll be very hard for him to get that
counter here the follow-up here
puts the brakes on gone with the lead
too
khan is gonna be your tlc master south
asia champion
right in the final final match a very
good valiant effort from bella taking it
all the way there but just too strong on
the day fate khan with the composure wow
what a tournament
what a tournament yeah one of the things
i noticed at the very end